have you been
like with sports this year has been so
[ __ ] weird me and your big sports
guys i know you're a big baseball guy
um have you what have you been thinking
so far of the way that
have you even been watching any baseball
this year or any sports at all because
it's been kind of it's been kind of
weird you'll wake up at like 11 a.m and
there'll be like a basketball game on
and and sunday there was basketball
football and baseball on which was
amazing because that's never happened
before yeah
i'm not investing my time in football
anymore because my team doesn't
isn't worth it so that are you a jets or
giants guy
what do you think i'm a jedi the giants
are worth they're still kind of worthy
you know they're trying
right the jets the jets aren't they try
what they're still discussing both adam
gates is terrible
it kind of just not worth it in general
so i don't waste time on sundays i
haven't really been watching tv
i listen to games a lot on the on the
radio so i like to listen to susan and
john
talk about the yankees you know so
that gets me happy and then i'm watching
ufc only
i'm watching bella i'm watching fights
whatever kickboxing whatever bellator or
whatever ufc is on i'm watching it
non-stop that's all i care about ufc has
done a great job of uh and it's in
it's you know for the past i don't know
from years now it's been the best sport
to follow for me
yeah that's fair it really it gives it's
it's a gift that keeps giving
yes i think it's uh also like the
like the the most like i think when you
watch any any sport for the most part
like you know there's load management in
the nba
there's just like some [ __ ] that you can
complain about when you watch ufc it's
like no it's two [ __ ] in the
middle of a ring
and that's all your body calls you out
if you [ __ ] duck somebody you're
getting called out if this happens
no matter it's like [ __ ] real [ __ ] no
matter what you have to see somebody you
have to [ __ ] go through them you have
to fight and that's then be that
if not you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
everyone knows it